muss das essen können heute da ist jesus
ist erleuchtet beleuchtet hallo ich
meine lieben freunde herzlich willkommen
zu einem neuen projekt auf den kanälen
von herbert nannte kauders soll und mir
hallöchen ihr beiden erst mal hallo
hallo hallo was genau was man valognes
alles klar bei euch das spiel wieder
hier eigentlich geht auch sammer spiele
ja eigentlich wir spielen ein
wunderschönes sehr entspanntes und eure
man sieht ja schon es ist wunderschön
ein wunderschönes webex mopac ob namens
und irgendwie haben sollte wird
begrüßung bisher wunderschönen hier wie
wir das alles regeln wir haben ja schon
kühl kuchen hingestellt für den kleinen
hunger und das ganze ist uns einfach
eingefallen weil wir haben gedacht nach
waren noch ein projekt wo wir alle mit
voller leidenschaft dabei waren total
ist adrenalin pur wenn man tot ist man
raus
man spielt die ganze band voller
anspannung haben wir uns gedacht wir
spielen jetzt ein projekt fast ein
bisschen was ein bisschen ruhiger
angehen wo wir ein paar sachen entdecken
können ich wünsche euch gerne zeigen was
es ja alles für items gibt es gibt
mehrere seiten im inventar ich bin hier
gerade im game mode also wir entschieden
uns hier nix aber es gibt wirklich ein
paar schöne sachen der club die schon so
schönes wasser kann ich euch auch ein
paar sachen zeigen wir sehen hier schon
ein rochen beispiels war also zwei
wochen sogar ein paar dinge die wir halt
hier einfach erkunden wollten so ein
bisschen ruhig das ganze angehen wollten
und dementsprechend ruhig haben uns auch
von den uploads angepasst das kann der
herr bergmann mal ganz kurz erklären
jetzt kommt schon weggelaufen
ja davon liegt dass wir das jetzt nicht
jede folge auf den auf einen kanälen
hochladen sondern jeder hat zwei slots
auf denen das hochlädt bei mir ist es
zum beispiel dienstags und freitags bei
dem lieben contractor ist des montags
und
donnerstags und bei kitas ist es
mittwochs und samstags und sonntags habt
ihr ein bisschen ruhe
wir wollten das nicht jetzt nicht
entspannen und alles verarbeiten
getränken normal alles angucken einfach
wir haben uns das nämlich nicht so
gedacht dass wir jeden tag jeder die
gleiche sicht auf jedem kanal hochlädt
sondern dass wir das wirklich abwechseln
opladen dass sie dann am montag von mir
was seht am dienstag von bergmann am
mittwoch von chaos und dann geht das
ganze wieder von vorne los also am
donnerstag freitag samstag dann wieder
die sichten und am sonntag pause
deswegen ist es auch hat es auch super
gepasst dass die erste folge jetzt hier
ist es schön dass du mein baum dazu ende
gefehlt hast es war ein anderer dass man
anderer ihr natürlich hab ich doch nicht
immer direkt den ersten folgen
unterstellt es unglaublich airways sind
das wäre halt nicht den stress an das
jeden tag drei folgen auf drei
verschiedenen kanälen kommen sondern
dass ihr euch das ein bisschen einteilen
können und deswegen würde ich sagen
viel spaß das muss uns jetzt so schön
gesagt sowieso noch erwähnen dass der
mai ist ja sowieso ohne zu viel zu
verraten so ein bisschen der der der
monat der megaprojekte und damit nicht
mehr so und deswegen haben wir dieses
projekt ausgesucht weil wir unbedingt
endlich mal was zusammen machen wollten
das ist ja auch für kontraste und mich
zum beispiel die erste gemeinsame
aufnahme und für chaos und mich ja auch
so mehr oder weniger ein paar kleine
dankeschön so etwas gibt es ja alles
nicht weiß und der wahrheit uns
unbedingt mehr kennenlernen wollten
während hier gerade ein unglaublich
gefährlicher schneesturm anfängt zu
ehrlich was sie trauen es ist wirklich
toll aus
ich hab es ja so wenig geredet es mir
gerade ihm aufgefallen wahrscheinlich
schreiben wir schon einige kommentare ob
ich traurig bin ja ich bin traurig sei
dass capcom das team groß okay das
müssen wir so lieb ja ich muss ja auch
irgendjemand hier so ein bisschen ihr
benutzt auch allem eine kräftige plus
ist das ist es hier irgendwie so family
sharing jahren einfach mal mit hier
morgen einfach mal dass sie das sieht
aus unglaublich hübsch also es ist lass
uns mal nicht hier lasst uns einmal
genauer erkunden lassen
nicht so schön aber ich mache einfach
mal ganz kurz ihren schwertern eine
spitzhacke hier das standard darauf ihr
seid ja drauf damit er hier war
natürlich vorsicht die nämlich mit
momentan nämlich mache ich das mit einer
spitzhacke hier
ich mache hier den dänischen staat
zombie der erste fight sagen nee das was
wir auch noch sagen wollte ist dass wir
ob man kuchen wo kommt denn überhaupt
hin
ich bleibe stehen bergmann nach süden
das ist immer so verwirrt von einer
ganzen schule ausflügen hier dann lasst
ihr mal jemand muss damit wieder den
dschungel weil uns alle irgendwie kuchen
zeigen möchte was hast du eigentlich
genau bietet einheits letzten das hast
du dich verletzt das würde schon öfters
mal gesagt was wir ja auch noch
ansprechen wollten war dass wir einen
twitter hashtag gemacht haben
welcher da heißt hashtag wald leben
wir haben jetzt gesagt wenn ihr nicht
leicht wenn du kurz weil das ein
bisschen doof ist und ein bisschen und
kreativ und da café das auch diesen
tollen gedanken nochmals auf wald leben
schöne parallele zu seinem leben
ich lerne ich hätte in frieden was ist
das da kann man nicht durchlaufen
das ziel ist aber noch mal ab ich habe
mich von der gruppe entfernt verloren
hat jetzt endlich auf deutsch und auf
englisch mal auf englisch
gerade eben ist aber auch schön aus hier
ne also schon mal alle mit es ist der
dschungel bio ich will irgendjemand
neues biom entdecken das ist ja wieder
mit tollen sachen man muss dazu sagen
server stellung richtig eingestellt
wurde aber bergmann ich hab dich wunder
brauchen wir lieber du vergleichende
worte ich wollte nur sagen
für uns ist der muss ja auch relativ neu
und es ist auch allgemein nicht so
bekannte smartpad aber man kann glaube
ich zumindest sagen verbessere mich
contractor wenn ich mich wenn ich mich
irre
das ist ihr begegnet so dermaßen
actionreiches oder sondern das ist er
darauf ausgelegt ist halt die schönheit
von minecraft noch mal neu zu entdecken
ich habe noch ein herz hirn im wasser
bleiben oder beim schwimmen derzeit auf
der stelle
ich wollte etwas geleuchtet aber um auch
mal mehrere ihre wunderschönen süßen
beweggründe für dieses projekt schon so
toll preisgegeben haben als wenn wir
hier so schön aus dem hut mit in der
runde gegen mountain ja seit war habe
ich um die mega lust mal wieder in
minecraft bisschen was zu bauen
menschen die meine solo webspace gesehen
haben wissen ich kann nicht bauen aber
ich muss trotzdem ist da freue ich mich
so ein bisschen drauf wenn das eigene
auge lebt seinen traum trägt das glaub
an deine träume okay dass ich nicht von
anderen einreden dass es nicht kannst
wir sollten nicht auch schon spenden
hier wie ich doch wie werden menschen
sterben
vor allem soll der spot point ja mal
komplett waren als es war ganz einfach
erst mal irgendwo lässt sich jetzt doch
erst mal schön
also ich sind jetzt ein paar neue bäume
was ist los bei mir ist das tal dunkel
bei mir euro bei mir ist es von einem
schlager von einer total
ich habe ganz kurz meinen shader
ausgemacht da musst dir noch
modifizieren dass sie das zu wenden wenn
hier der mond aufgehen wahrscheinlich
dann dauert das ein bisschen ist das
licht hier bei den shadern durchkommt ja
krass heftig dunkel von einem schlagen
können bergmann muss jetzt für uns sehen
bitte an einem herz gehe ich gerne frei
ich bin hinter bergbahnen aber auch nie
mehr so etwas unterfordert und rüstung
und buben leute ich geh nicht vor
morgen der nächsten folge oder danach
werde ich das ich bin einfach weiter in
dem ich nicht sehe das ist bei mir von
war schon gewohnt sterben ohne quatsch
geht nicht zurück geht zurück ich pack
das muss doch etwas essen können hier
heute da ist jesus gleich weiß ist
erleuchtet beleuchtet hier von rechts
auch über alle märkte nochmal mit ihm
auf und klatscht stehen jetzt dollar ich
habe dort meine reise am herzen
moment ich muss jetzt auch mein shader
ausschalten ansonsten sieht sich einfach
nicht einfach gar nichts wir suchen da
schon in geregelte bahnen
ich hätte ich etwas geschlafen freude
dadurch entspannt durch die bvb profis
am start
da kommen wir noch zombies und alle
kinos kommt sich alles über jene die
zombie ich nämlich clutches gelebt macht
den jesus platz so jesus ohne spinne
eine spinne ich kann nicht sprechen sie
hat mich gleich ein thema so können uns
bei twitter unter dem hashtag wald leben
sie im schreiben drei herzen drei herzen
wir müssen raus edeljoker aber ganz
schnell meint meinen wenn die schweren
sich auch krupp war
ich bin genauso wie bergmann grad total
gehandicapt ich hab drei herzen und zwei
seilen ein spannendes projekt leute gar
kein ding
bei all dem ist der traum vom bischof
schottland ist ja das bonbon ist völlig
woanders nicht sagen
beim export mich zu dir ja ich muss
erstmal aus
nebenbei dazu zu erwähnen also nicht
aufnehmen drei folgenden ärgern ich habe
absolute note alu und not
marien jetzt hier sportlich gerade es
ist dunkel ist der outdoor instant genau
die kombination richtig laute sound
scheder ist der mega dunkel bei nacht
ich komme die braunen erforderten kripo
an den kinokassen prima
dafür werde ich auch noch mal irgendwas
an der server schwierig krebs erinnern
ich habe ein herzlich willkommen hier
konnte intel center nicht richtig
fleisch ihr merkmal das ist ein richtig
richtig entspannt ist projekt ist das
sind was ist los ich lass mal beteiligen
die nacht überleben ob in jedem fall
einfach laufen
ich habe nur noch ein herzen komm mal
her hier kommen hier ist alles und ich
muss man auf jeden fall in anderen
shader holen
das ist ja heute danach wird alles na ja
also es wird auf jeden fall noch nicht
ihr seht es wirklich ist es mehr ein
spaßprojekt als jetzt irgendwie hier die
mega ernste ober packung abertausend
regeln oder so ehrlich gesagt ziemlich
lustig dass wir alles super entspanntes
projekt und damit ist das mega gemäß
legal eignet in der eben erst mal ganz
kurz app können wir ganz kurz dann noch
mal zu ende quatschen das versagen
wollten und zwar ihr könnt uns themen
schreiben bei twitter unter hashtag
waldleben ihr könnt uns allerdings auch
tipps und tricks schreiben falls sie
irgendeine musik antz deswegen verlinken
euch dass sie eine beschreibung das
ganze könnt ihr in der in den
kommentaren tun
ja ich hab ja sogar blut menü drin und
du du du hast wieder voll ein rein
ach ja und was los ich hab einfach
kommen alle anliegen echt alle die
wieder solcher weise gemacht dass das
nachts auf gott dass das so ein problem
macht ja und irgendwie hell bleibt dann
können wir das okay bekommen schreiben
denn ich habe keine ahnung von sowas
das ist bei mir auch bisher dürfen also
wir werden das alles auch das wird sich
verbessern von lauf zu lauf
wir bitten alle schlagen schon wieder
die schlinge kann ins wasser was denn da
los
wir sind ständig schlagen will ich hier
bin ich bin ich fertig bin und werde ich
eben den billig wenn ich noch nicht aus
krebs und die alle richtig auf krawall
gebürstet bergmann kontrolliere ich bin
doch kein einziges normales super
durchfalle töte schön gold teleportiert
ich mich zum ok ich will jetzt lasst mal
parieren konnte seine hilfe nicht an
hilfe sind immer aus wie tot
warum wir machen ich hätte dich komm zu
mir du bist du also nur aus gips an
dieser wirklichen krebs der mich auch
noch attackiert ja ich hab was ich
brauch mal was zu essen oder oder oder
wie wir das jetzt machen ihm bergmann
will ab moderieren ich will was zu essen
ja in kinos hilfe doch mal eben jede
läuft einfach an mir vorbei mit meinem
problem bergmann nach ich glaube da muss
man sich kümmern das ist so jemand beim
was wenn jemand beim klassenausflug nein
das ist ja mal das ist ja immer so eine
chaos aufnahme gerade 15
ich schütze dich kommen bei mir noch
kühl dass die kühe meisten hacker das
als einziges mal eben jetzt erstmal die
erste folge dann ist tag und danone
rüsten uns erst mal richtig aus der
bäckerei wollte auch direkt weg gehen
die leute das alles die schuld des
lehrers hier schützt sich vor den
zombies
ja ja denn überhaupt gerade ich bin hier
an doch ich sehe euch ich weise seines
kombis wesentlich aggressiver sind hier
in die moderne
ja ich sehe das doch ich will ich will
ich glaube ich werde die schwierigkeit
auch mal ein bisschen modifiziert jahren
die school ich mag das macht spaß
die super bowl blumen das ist so davis
das wäre so ein schönes romantisches
lila pink ist ein wort verkehr t
das könnte das dell muss irgendwas
angestellt sei nicht verändert
also ich hab noch nie so viele zombies
hingegen ein projekt gesehen und wird
sich sind drei stück das ist die
absolute sieglos bei mir sind zehn
hinter mir ja das war aber möglich das
hättest du gard sehen müssen das war wie
im horrorfilm sie die spinne so um die
ecke laufen ja und dann mach ich hier
richtig reisen weko hast du hast du r
fleisch sammeln können ich habe noch mal
gucken wie viel ich habe hier oben hier
oben man das ist echt ein 1 1 ein spaß
hier
wir haben jetzt eine super platz
gefunden naja bin ich auch das ist hier
ist im freistaat das war ein graus weil
ich habe hier ein robbie verschoben wird
effekt ich danke dir bald aufgesammelt
aber ich gebe euch kann uns auf jeden
fall ein crafting tablett machen damals
erst mal schön
bisher wissen wir saves sogar noch
mannschaft im tempel musst du bist das
geht aus einem report
ich bin doch ich bin auch schon gab es
neben mir steht wenig solchen zeiten
sollte noch einmal schwerter sponsoren
wahrscheinlich wieder warten sonst alles
mancini an affen kinos jetzt boxt man
sich einfach von mir da jetzt hat jetzt
macht spaß ist genauso schön wenn sie
sich wehren können das magnificat mache
ich auch sehr gerne in berliner
u-bahnhöfen kommt auf dich zu aber nur
auf puren krawall gebürstet und fängt an
es wird langsam wieder tag freunde
das heißt kann den shader urlaub machen
das ist ein traum an und ausschalten
hier wie wunderschön aber oder komplett
dass die spider die hat schon ein
bisschen erst geht es glaube ich was das
hochgehen angeht gesagt muss
wenn wir aggressiv die auf waren also
dass das ist richtig das ist das ist
nicht mehr normal ich dachte wirklich
das letzte java kommen wir bauen ihre
parolen und so aber jetzt war sie das
schön aus wenn der vermieter brennt ich
könnte auf jeden fall richtig lustig
werden also ich hab mir gerade richtig
bock darauf bekommen ehrlich gesagt also
noch mehr als ich eh schon hat eben
durch diesen die fliesen action aspekt
ja das würdig adrenalin-schub verpasst
ich habe mir auch so gedacht so am
anfang okay bleibt in der wurst
schilling ist vielleicht ganz gut nach
faro aber das ist ja schön dass diese
beiden aspekte miteinander verbunden
werden also wir haben jetzt einerseits
die wunderschöne landschaft hier mit
ganz ganz vielen dingen die
beispielsweise möbel die wir uns bauen
können aber auf der anderen seite ihr
merkt ja relativ viel konkurrenz was das
angeht ja action ohne ende
ich habe die ganzen wochen getötet habt
es zwei wochen gift bekommen bergmann
willst du das vergessen geraten ist kann
ich wenn ich vielleicht ganz gut für die
für die leber oder so was viele
verbraucher rating ok freunde kommen das
ist das ist actionreich gerade wir
sollten wir sollten ein höhepunkt
sollten wir auch blind du bist sind also
wie ich habe blind ist aber ich sehe
alles nur der himmel schwarz okay und
ich fress gerade das fleisch aber ich
würde auch sagen dass jetzt eine kleine
abmoderation für die erste folge nicht
abzubauen
in der nächsten episode mit wir immer so
ein bisschen wir wollen ja doch diesen
diesen weg zwischen entspannt und kassa
action den wir jetzt hier gefunden haben
wollte aber ich will ich will ich will
sagen wir gehen ob die kleine stücke der
nächsten folge dann haben wir auch ein
bischen tag
diese machen wollen wir wollen wir alles
aufnehmen auf diese kleinen wege also
wirklich dass das die nächste folge dann
da beginnt wo die vorherige aufgehört
habt desto mehr würde ich sagen werdet
ihr dann sehen in der nächsten folge die
dennoch in einem
einer kommt deswegen dass wir erst mal
die erste folge das prinzip lässt ihn
noch habt ihr am anfang schon gehört von
dem uploaden ab jetzt auf jedem kanal
bei bergmann dienstag und freitag können
wir alles in die video beschreibt last
eine bewertung daran und ich sagen
tschüss das war's gut genau